I have a little old-fashioned cringe for
you radical and repugnant reactionary
Republican congresswoman Lauren bobert
is very concerned about public urination
but so much so that she ended up making
a complete and total fool of herself
during a recent hearing there's a little
write-up in uh Rolling Stone about this
Lauren bobert obsesses over public
urination at crime hearing Lauren bobert
waylaid a congressional hearing on crime
in Washington D.C
by grilling DC city council member
Charles Allen on what she insisted were
efforts to decriminalize public
urination it turns out that he didn't
actually do that you have to see this
clip this is unbelievable and the guy is
increasingly visibly confused because he
doesn't know what the hell she's talking
about
check this out and uh these charges
these changes
are now law here in DC correct
do you mean the revised criminal code
yes uh no those are not the law okay
first question was this is now the law
answer it is not the law not the law did
with the revised Revised Code was
rejected by excuse me Mr chairman I
talked to Mr Allen Mr Allen did you or
did you not decriminalize public
urination in Washington DC did you lead
the charge to do so no it the revised
criminal code left that as a criminal
charge did you
suanimous but she keeps going the charge
to decriminalize public urination in
Washington D.C no ma'am did you ever
vote in favor of decriminalizing public
urination in Washington D.C the revised
criminal code did you ever support kept
it as a criminal offense did you did and
you support this criminal I voted for it
yeah you voted
[Music]
this is going so wrong and it's
absolutely delightful to keep it as a
criminal offense that's correct
wait so you're telling me
you never advocated to make public
urination not a crime you never voted to
make it not a crime and you voted to
keep it a crime yes hmm interesting that
now I'm now I'm not sure
Congress is devolving rapidly you know
I think we as a community of the left
we expected
that when Republicans took over the
House of Representatives it would become
a circus Sideshow I think we expected
that but the degree to which it has
become a circus side show is genuinely
surprising even to me and I've been I've
been doing this you know quite a long
time
um after the fourth time she brings up
public urination
I probably would have lost it if I was
in that room and it is just stunning and
the takeaway here is
well I don't know what the takeaway here
is if Lauren bobert
is thinking about urinating in public
which I guess is a concern for her it is
still a crime
um these people are genuinely a joke and
we laugh to a certain degree to avoid
crying but I get emails from European
viewers all the time in fact let me see
if I can pull one up uh I'm not even
sure
you're I'm not even sure how I'm going
to be able to do this
anyway I get so many emails from people
saying David what is happening in your
country here's just one as an example
I'm going to just read this I don't want
to put the person I didn't blank it out
um from the Netherlands someone wrote in
and said David I I am encouraging you on
your quest to educate people in the
United States what on Earth is going on
your thoughts and Visions are clearly
needed in the United States it is a
crisis what is wrong with so many
Americans I was brought up with the
United States as a role model now the
United States is a joke barely anything
positive is connected to the United
States particularly because of the
Republican party we increasingly see the
USA negatively because of these lunatics
I understand that this is not your
movement but it is a direct result of
the populistic rhetoric that you
criticize being misused by the
Republican party and these complete and
total clowns most people here did like
Barack Obama but Trump was ridiculed and
now it seems as though there is no
turning back this is just an example
okay that's rhymed from uh from the net
Netherlands from Amsterdam every single
day we are a global laughing stock and
it's not just anecdotally it's reflected
in public opinion polls about how people
see the United States and how people see
the office of the presidency we've got
to do something to turn it around and
another four years of trump isn't going
to turn it around and certainly four
years of Ron DeSantis won't either